I truly consider myself a complete  moderate complete moderate I mean I I I  truly believe that honestly a two-party  system is ridiculous because what we're  having to accept now is you either have  to it's it's a it's a it's by you know  bipartisan extremes right if you have to  accept the extremes of each of each  party  even though the like the most rational  you know decision or point of view is  always going to be more in the middle do  you know what I'm saying so it's like if  you you have to you're forced to like  pick a side  and then cosine even the most extreme  ideologies of that side  just because it's just because you're  picking the lesser of two evils